welcome to the class on personal
genomics in your health this really is
the topic of personalized medicine and
really the goal of personalized medicine
is to customize health care so that we
can really treat the individual rather
than the masses who might have a
particular disease perhaps equally
importantly what this course is going to
do it's going to cover the role of
genetics and genomics in managing
personalized health and also in this
great shift where we're trying to shift
from treating disease after symptoms
have occurred to be able to ultimately
predict and prevent disease and really
that's one of the major goals of
precision and personalized medicine so
in this course we're going to learn
about lots of different aspects of
personalized medicine a genomic medicine
we're learn about general methods for
acquiring genetic information for
medical and consumer testing learn about
pharmacogenomics in the role of genetics
and drug response we're learning about
considerations for interpreting genomes
and genetic variants which is still very
tricky business we also talked about the
technology and its accuracy and where it
currently stands we're going to talk
about the various challenges for
bringing genomics into the clinic it's
not a very trivial issue and finally
we're going to talk about the pros and
cons of clinical genetic testing in all
the different aspects of Medicine so
this is where we're going it's going to
be exciting class I think you're going
to learn a lot and we'll tell you what
we know about this area and ideally
where some of the future is in a space
as well